basically they went into the back end of
Twitter and they found that some people
were being quote unquote Shadow banned
or uh filtered is what Twitter calls it
and basically they would have like
different sensors that they could put on
different accounts that they could
either like stop you from being searched
so it'd be harder for people to find you
like through search they can actually
stop uh the amount of people that have
shown your Tweet and the ones that uh
Barry put out I might pronounce that as
a barrier Bari Barry is Barry right and
Barry basically said it was like mostly
right-wing people like Dan bongino and
uh people from like Turning Point USA
and stuff like that it was mostly
right-wing accounts so the the way it's
painted at least is that there's a uh
slant against right wing commentators on
Twitter to like censor their their
content now would you say that this is
also a function of the people working
for Twitter
in the same way that that other thing
that came out to remember they were like
um they were silencing like both like
the Biden thing where like they were
able to pull off the laptop stores yeah
and they were able to pull up uh pull
off other Republican stories uh but
there were just more Democrats working
at Twitter so that more Democrats had
access to those people so more stories
get taken down the other thing I can't
verify is whether or not they broke
terms of service and if in their own
internal terms of service if they have
uh like hey if you break this thing
where your profile is going to be
quote-unquote Shadow band I think the
thing so if it was already in there
they're not breaking any rules the thing
that people are frustrated about is that
uh supposed to do the Creative Twitter
what's his name uh Jack Dorsey Dorsey
said that they don't Shadow Ben that's
the thing where they come out and it's
like I love that I love what Elon said
when he was basically like we're gonna
do that he goes everybody has freedom of
speech but you don't have freedom of
reach so what we will do is like Notch
down fill uh Notch down your uh
visibility if you're saying racist
things or hateful things I think he said
he'll actually show when you are being
Shadow banned now oh yeah yeah so it's
just uh dude that's what you're talking
about caring about it yeah that's better
yo here's the thing like people fall in
line like it's so funny like Tick Tock
will take down a clip because we curse
you know we take away from Tick Tock now
jerseys the curses Instagram will take
away a video for whatever you know we
take down the video for that whatever
the [ __ ] they're saying it's like people
will conform because we're using this
thing to access millions of people for
free now I understand you know if you're
not paying for the product you're on the
product whatever that [ __ ] saying is
but at the same time all you need to do
is just give a little bit of a
punishment and then people will fall in
line it's really interesting because we
value more being able to access these
people uh than we do like holding true
to saying the word [ __ ] in a statement
yeah like as long as the rules are
generally clear like I don't think
people care that much about the rules as
long as like they're fair and equal for
everyone yeah I think it's like when
it's all nebulous and it's like am I
Shadow band like how many times have you
been Shadow banned off of Instagram or
whatever I would way rather no or like
Duval just tell me Duvall got Shadow
band like a bunch of accounts get Shadow
banned it's like what is happening why
no transparency yeah on Facebook and you
can't even appeal it you can't ask
anything about it it's just like this
thing happens to you and then you're
just stuck but I think it'll be great if
he actually like shows that your Shadow
Ben and the reasoning why you are that'd
be amazing I wonder if it's the one
thing that he's doing good I wonder if
it's actually more effective now I'm not
saying I like it as much but I wonder if
it's more effective the way that
Instagram does it where they just Shadow
ban you and there's no real way to
communicate with them there's no real
way to have a conversation with them
they're just like these are the rules
and if you break them you're gone and
you break enough of those rules you
start going
you either decide you go I don't want to
[ __ ] with this app no more or you go all
right I Gotta Buy by the [ __ ] rules
the fact that you can have a
conversation with someone at Twitter and
argue with them and then do this whole
legalese thing where you're like well
technically it's not a trans joke if you
really look at it like this you're going
to be spending millions of dollars on
just random [ __ ] conversations with
trolls on the internet well you keep
people on the app more though because
that's really what matters at the end of
the day that's true if you're that much
less inclined to use Instagram either
because you don't want to deal with the
rules or because you feel like it's less
fun then you're hurting your product
right now there's no competition beside
I mean Tick Tock is obviously
combination but they have even more
strict rules yeah so it's like if
there's no other competition you can go
to [ __ ] parlor truth social or these
other places they're just like troll
fields of people screaming the n-word
and putting up swastikas and [ __ ] just
to prove that they can there's no real
content there you don't want to like
exist there on your content
so I'm not saying what I like I want to
be able to say whatever I want what I'm
saying is if I was running a company you
want a policy that allows people to act
in the way that you want them to act
yeah with by doing the least amount of
administration possible I think Tick
Tock does they just tell you why like
cussing or and sometimes it's still
vague but it's they're a little bit more
explicit and why you go so you're like
all right now I know what to do whereas
with a shadow band you don't know what
the [ __ ] is happening somebody said Tell
Your Shadow band you don't know what's
going on and it's just so ambiguous and
there's no Clarity yeah and then you're
just hey let's get rid of anything that
could be
fun or whatever so then basically say
okay your your shadow man for a week
it's going to limit the amount of people
that can see your content yada yada
that's what you would prefer you're
saying no yeah I prefer yeah this hey
you broke this rule your Shadow band
this lasts for a week all right I know
what I did I know what I'm gonna do to
fall in line I think that's what Mark
said earlier as long as it's even as
long as everybody's playing by the same
rules and it felt as if it wasn't for
Twitter at least that's the way they
presented I don't know and I didn't read
every single tweet of like the whole
thread but it's that's the example she
brought up yeah yeah I like that like
having some sort of constitution like a
digital Constitution if you will of the
things that like we can accept and this
is all going to be based on more or less
like where advertisers are going to
spend their dollars yeah it's really
funny like what if advertisers just all
came together and said yo we don't care
if people curse we don't care if people
make jokes about marginalized groups we
don't care about anything we just want
the views all these rules would go away
yeah Oh you mean America in the 90s yeah
100 sure right like isn't that
interesting they're not doing this for
some sort of like um uh moral uh taking
like a moral High ground or trying to
like virtue signal they're trying to
feed their bottom line which makes sense
you're a business yeah this is not a uh
the irony is Twitter is probably the at
most responsible for companies having to
act like this now because people used to
take all their outrage there they got
negative PR and then they would be like
all right we have to change everything
more diversity to be more it's like
constantly concerned about perception
before social media before Twitter yeah
we 10 of us would get upset a thousand
of us would get upset whatever where do
we go with that you know we sit in our
house and you got to look up the [ __ ]
number and call the headquarters 99
people aren't doing it yeah yeah Nabisco
I don't think letter or an email come on
bro and you know what's funny is that we
could get away from this Advertiser
model if everybody just paid for Twitter
yeah which is literally what what Elon
suggesting now there's no way in [ __ ]
hell we will do that yeah so because
we're not willing to pay for it we're
gonna have to accommodate certain rules
that they have
we and we can't [ __ ] cry about it
like what are we supposed to say I
should be able to do whatever I want in
your restaurant yeah that's the rule
yeah for free for free and eat for free
yeah
and make money off your I should be able
to sell my food in your restaurant yeah
however the [ __ ] I want
and
not be criticized in any way shape or
form for it I understand why they have
frustration especially with us when we
complain I understand from the company's
perspective they're like [ __ ]
you ain't even paying for this [ __ ] yeah
and you have millions of followers and
you're able to monetize those millions
of followers from our platform and
you're gonna be upset that we don't let
you say the word [ __ ] or you're gonna be
upset that we'll let you say the N word
yeah like that's your pushback
what I don't like is
and Duo pointed this [ __ ] out when the
rules
when the rules lack an understanding of
diversity and culture so dubo is
basically like yo there's no black
people they're on the board so these
[ __ ]
um there's nobody on the boards of these
um
they're like monitoring the comments and
monitoring the content and he goes so
they're thinking that certain things
that exist with exist within Black
Culture that are not bullying or being
critical at all calling someone stupid
calling someone dumb for being funny
yeah are you stupid are you dumb those
comments were getting flagged yeah as
bullying so so he goes yo they're making
it so we can't even be black yeah I
thought that was a great Point what
happened to Weezy she got like a shadow
bear because she put like yes [ __ ] or
whatever and they didn't realize that so
now that's an adjustment that they can
obviously make but to me when he said
that I was like yo that's the most
profound criticism of Instagram or
social media I've ever seen it's like
it's it's social media is going to
dictate culture and you make it
essentially illegal for aspects of Black
Culture Latino culture Asian culture
like Italian culture to exist there
because they can be viewed food as bully
or they can be viewed as insensitive
you're making a very homogeneous culture
that's going to lose all the flavor that
we love
you know what I'm saying yeah yeah
Twitter without black Twitter it's not
Twitter bro come on bro it's not Twitter
bro yeah